What's up everyone! We are going to look at a very important topic today in economics. This is demand, or
when people have the willingness and ability to buy product.
Let's jump into it.
We have a demand schedule on the left and we are buying pizzas. Yum!
You'll notice we have two variables: price and quantity demanded.
Also as the price decreases from $25 to $5 the quantity demanded rises from 0 to
40,000 pizzas. Tthis is what we call the law of demand that is as, there isn't, there is an inverse relationship between the price of a good and the quantity demanded of that good, ceteris paribus. This is an important concept as it applies to just about everything that we could buy.
Do you want to pay more for something or less for it? Are you going to buy more pizzas at $10 or at $20?
You can buy two pizzas at $10 each compared to just one pizza at $20. Let's go ahead and sketch these numbers in our graph to the right.
We are going to label the vertical axis with price.
And the horizontal axis with quantity.
Now let's put the numbers in.
And let's put some dots in there.
And we're going to connect these dots.
And there we have it!
A demand curve. This curve shows the pairing of the individual prices and their respective quantities. As we move down along this curve
you'll notice that the quantity demanded rises,
and the price falls. As we move up along this demand curve you'll notice that the quantity demanded rises, or excuse me, falls as the price rises.
Basically any time the price of a good changes we get a change in quantity demand.
So to change the quantity demanded, and this important, we have to change the price of the good.
What happens if something other than the price changes? Suppose
income rises for people.
So here
we're going to change colors, If income rises we may see a complete change in the demand curve that is we're going to have an increase in demand.
Suppose however income falls, and if that happens then we may see people willing and able to buy less
pizzas, so we have a decrease in demand. So I've denoted an increase in demand as that red line and you'll notice that this is a shift to the
right on this set of axes and a decrease in demand is a shift left of the original demand curve and it is denoted by that purple demand curve.
In this next table, we have a new quantity that changed because of some factor other than price. If incomes rose, then at each
price people are willing and able to purchase
more pizzas. This shifts the demand curve to the right.
So let's draw in a new demand curve.
And we'll label are horizontal axis Q for quantity and are vertical axis P for
price. Now let's also go ahead and make this new demand curve.
We'll call this D1, and this is the increase in demand, And this is occurring because we have now gone from our old quantity to our new quantity which increased by 5,000 pizzas at each
price.
There are quite a few determinants of demand. We've
already mentioned one and that is a change in incomes.
To go along with a change in incomes we can separate goods into normal goods and inferior goods. With normal goods,
increase in incomes will lead to an increase in demand.
And a decrease in incomes will lead to a decrease in demand.
This is the case for many of the goods that we buy.
But inferior goods do the opposite.
An increase in income causes a decrease in demand.
And a good like margarine is a good example of this. People tend to switch away from margarine and towards butter as their incomes increase. But if their incomes decrease we see the exact opposite behavior.
Our next tournament is the size and composition of the population.
As more people enter into an area then the demand for that product is likely to go up.
Likewise as population decreases so too will the demand for products.
The baby boom generation was one of the largest generations. As they grow older they will also need more medical services so what we see is an increase in the older population and the demand from that will increase.
A change in tastes and preferences for a particular good also affects demand.
Suppose that a study proves pizza to be beneficial to your health. What's going to happen? It's likely that people will consume more pizza
as their tastes are switched to it.
So we get an increase in demand. But if that study said the opposite then we would see a decrease in demand for pizzas.
People also like to plan for the future. So they are forward-looking. Suppose we expect the price of pizza.
to fall next week.
If that happens then we are likely to see a decrease in our consumption today. So a price of the pizza is expected to fall next week then the demand for pizza
is going to decrease today.
The opposite is true. If we expect the price of pizza to rise next week then we can expect to see a demand for pizza today to increase.
Suppose that we are expecting a raise next week.
What might we do today?
What might we do
today?
If our income is expected to increase next week then we might go out and celebrate today by buying more pizzas. However suppose that we expect to get laid off next week, so our income stream is going to go away.
What might happen today? Well our demand for pizzas is likely to decrease and that's because we're going to need to start saving more in order to buy the things that we absolutely need in the future. Our last to determinate deals with the change in the price of related goods. There are two types we want to deal with. The first is complements. No, we aren't complimenting how nice looking the pizza is.
We are looking at what we can pair with pizza.
Perhaps beer is a good complement.
If the price of beer
decreases then the demand for pizza is likely to increase.
That's because we expect people to buy more pizza as they find the more savings from beer purchases, from their beer purchases can now go towards pizza.
So they have a good Friday night!
The opposite is true as well. If the price of beer increases then we expect to see the demand for
pizza purchases
to decrease.
The second type of related goods is substitutes. Here we are looking for food that people switch to as a preference other than pizza.
Suppose lasagna,
is a good substitute for pizza.
If the price of lasagna increases then the demand for pizza
Will also increase and that is because people are switching away from the high price lasagna towards the lower-cost pizza.
If the price of lasagna decreases then we can expect to see the demand for pizza to also decrease as people switch away from the high price pizza to the low
cost lasagna.
The last thing that we want to talk about is that you'll notice that with these determinants the price of pizza never changed that is all we had was a shift
in the demand curve either an increase or a decrease.
This is important to note this distinction between the change
in quantity demanded, which is a movement along the demand curve.
And that's caused by a change in the price of the good.
Versus a change in demand which is caused by one of the determinants of demand.
Alright, that's it. We'll see you in the next video.